[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you tapped into the group chat live from
the bluetooth report app
presented by fanduel
hey here we are the big three in
brooklyn
has put the nba on notice that it's
going to be a problem
your big three right here you don't have
any problems we're here to give you
answers
my name is cabby richards our betting
expert's in the middle that is kelly
stewart and our baby face assassin from
the
yaya his name is greg ivory
look every week we go head-to-head
against the great charles barkley in our
favorite segment called
chuck versus america america you guys
pick the prop
and we ride with you and sometimes chuck
rides with us
or sometimes chuck fades us last week we
all voted
that steph curry would score more than
four and a half three-pointers
now charles barkley he went the other
way in the head-to-head matchup he said
that damian lillard would score more
than five three-pointers
in a game let's take a look at what
happened
four and a half three pointers made by
dame lillard
and by steph curry
[Music]
it's like having a cheat code
dame lillard or steph curry both guys
can just shoot the lights out
listen they both made over four and a
half three pointers last week
dame hit five steph hit five so we won
it was a push with charles barkley we
improved to 7-0 and charles barkley
improves to three and four let's see the
standings america
there we are right at the top we have a
comfortable
four-game cushion and we remain
undefeated
versus chuck uh as steph curry went off
last week and is playing tonight
greg ivory is going to be our volume
shooter when giving away hoodies
tabby i'm in the comments yes yes yes
you guys know what this is right here
this is the handy dandy ipad
and i am in the comments uh
i got deep geek deep geek says uh one of
our
favorites dude good intro cabbie chuck
isn't smart
uh shout out to cabbie shouts out to you
d geek you're walking away with a hoodie
i got patriots uh 20 21 they said
yes yes yes they're rocking with us
being seven and oh
shout out to you patriots 2021. uh
cavi uh that that's that's it for the
comments okay
comments let's let's get this show
moving let's get it moving
that's right yeah it's it's we're not
gonna sprint through this we know you
have many more
hoodies to give away so let's get to
tonight's action it is time for the
chuck
versus america bet 4 this evening we
asked you on social earlier today on
br betting who will score more in their
head-to-head matchup tonight
stephen curry or luca doncic again
another box office matchup
according to the twitter results steph
curry is in the lead
with 60 of the votes maybe it's a
recency bias because he did drop 38
points against a great boston squad
in this last game but for right now
steph curry
is leading in the head-to-head matchup
who will score more points
um g-money can you be objective
in this particular scenario or are you
going to go with your heart what kind of
question is that we already know
greg can't be objective this is like the
warriors
fan profile i know but i was just i was
just
i'm just putting like a nugget out there
like maybe he'll take the nugget
and be objective in this particular
head-to-head matchup maybe
ah listen listen i'm gonna be objective
i'm i'm
just gonna go off of facts stat uh facts
only
facts and facts only now i need the
audience to do me a favor i need you
guys
to comment let us know who we are riding
with should we ride with steph
or should we ride with luca so you guys
let me know in the comments
and uh we're gonna get right into it but
kelly you talk to the people let them
know
who are you riding with is it steph or
is it uh
luca look i think steph is the obvious
play here
as cabbie said when you first look at
this you go what happened
lately and that is steph curry doing
what steph curry does
in shooting the absolute rock but i
think luca
had some troubles there i know that he
tried to beat the signs he couldn't get
it done that was expensive for me
but that was another show that i do with
cabbie that being said
look porzingis is back in the lineup but
i think that is going to help
luca it's going to help him with the
assist that's going to help him with the
rebounds
what's that mean that means he's going
to have more opportunity to shoot the
ball i kind of like luca tonight i'm not
going to lie
there's a lot of weight on steph curry's
shoulders to be the offensive engine
of the golden state warriors same amount
of weight is on luca's
shoulders to be the engine for the
dallas mavericks and as kelly said
you know there are pieces that have come
back to play maxi clebur's back
dorian finney smith is back kristaps
porzingis is back
luca almost had a triple-double
yesterday against
atlanta and those other players allow
him to be more
of a play-maker but here's here's where
where luke is going to win in the
margins tonight the free throw line
he's getting back he's getting more
aggressive so he's getting those
opportunities at the free throw line
luca just has to outscore steph by one
point and that will be the difference at
the free throw line tonight
mr objectivity greg ivory what say you
about the matchup today cabbie let me
get into the comments first let me get
into the comments
i got the handy dandy ipad here i got
loft burn
he says he's rocking with steph i got
zebra
one two three actually zebra one two
three is just repeating their comments
but they're rocking with luga do not
repeat comments that's not how you get
hoodie zebra one two three unfortunately
i cannot give you a hoodie there
here we go back into the comments cabbie
i got vegan girl 14 she's rocking
with steph i got uh max i cry more
is rocking with steph uh i don't see any
luca love
in here cabbie at all i mean i don't
really see
any okay i got yeah i i
know luca love bro i mean zebra zebra123
is like the loner in the comments
that's rocking with luca but let me give
you guys why
i mean the commenters are saying steph
and why i say steph all right let me
just break it down
to you guys all right steph right now
currently
right now at this at this moment he
leads the league in total points
scored he leads the league in total
points scored steph curry leading
leading the lead cabbie
just want to let him impressive all
right let's move on let me move on
per game now let's go to per game now
let's look at steph curry he has 28.2
luca 27.2 so the facts are there
the facts are there steph curry the
facts are right there the proof is in
the pudding cavi
steph curry i'm rocking with steph the
people is rocking with steph
i mean the facts are there okay fine all
right well let's just like you you made
a decent argument
but you never know what's going to
happen that both both defenses aren't
great
so you know i'm going to take the over
in that particular game with the totals
but it could be a 31 to 30 or 36 to 33
type of scoring output for both of those
uh all-stars so
um listen check out uh inside the nba's
pre-game show on tnt to see where
charles
leans it seemed it looks like we are all
riding with steph curry tonight so
charles may ride with us or he might
fade us but make sure you check out the
pregame show
to see where chuck leans and uh also
don't forget to
jump on fanduel and lock in steph curry
to outscore luka doncic
tonight in uh warriors versus mavericks
at 7 30 eastern
and also don't forget to send us our
videos if you feel inclined to make one
because we love watching them and we
love featuring them
on our show the most fun you can have in
america right now as far as betting goes
is the three by two we invented this bet
for you and for us too because it's
amazing
and it's an absolute riot it's quite
simply this
will there be two three-pointers scored
in the first three minutes of a game
it's a quick hitter that we all love two
three pointers made
in the first three minutes of the game
now last week
unfortunately we decided to ride with
yes in the portland and houston game
and there are actually zero
three-pointers made in the first three
minutes
so then we doubled down we went you know
we see you golden state in phoenix
we doubled down and that one hit america
so
we are seven and two so far this year in
the three by two
so salute to devin booker chris paul uh
steph curry kelly ubre all those dudes
for helping us hit the three by two and
tonight
we're looking at golden state and dallas
7 30 p.m eastern again will there be two
three-pointers made
in the first three minutes of the game
g-money i need you to tap in with your
army
all right i need everybody in the
comments to just
say yes give me gifts saying yes give me
uh
emojis i guess saying yes if you can get
creative
uh or just type yes or no
don't really say no but yeah get in the
comments let us read some of your
emojis yes emojis we know the only
person that ever says no is cabbie it's
totally fine
yeah so so get into those comments get
into those comments
kelly now give us your take well last
week you rode with us last week we were
riding with kelly
uh do we got the kelly approval today
greg i've been riding every week because
let me tell you
what's going on nobody's playing defense
in the first three minutes of the game
it just doesn't
happen it just doesn't so look right now
we're seven and two on the year i don't
care if we're five and four on the year
we're still making money and that's all
you have to remember
we're betting this until we're no longer
making money yes
yes yes yes yes listen g-money loves to
have his sunset vibes when you tap in on
the on
instagram live you know and
unfortunately i'm going to
bring some precipitation and a cloud
cloud movement into the mix into that
beautiful picturesque
uh scenery look
dallas hasn't had a three by two in the
last five games
zero in five games so we're relying
heavily on steph curry or kelly ubre or
g money's new uh object of affection
andrew wiggins to hit a three-pointer
hit hit two in the first three minutes
so i'm saying i'm leaning no on this one
tonight guys mostly because
dallas last year had a historic offense
but since steven silas is now coaching
the houston rockets
the output hasn't been the same so i'm
leaning no on the 3x2 and i'm sorry to
bring
a whole storm front onto your sunset
vibes do you money
greg apparently he hasn't heard our new
anthem yet like he's just behind
in every aspect of this team mentality
petite biscuit yeah cavi i mean
it sounds like you know about it but let
me hop into these comments let me hop
into these comments guys
uh cuz uh i'm seeing a whole and i mean
a whole bunch of yeses
uh we got mikey 824 with a yes we got uh
raimi uh j-o-c-h-e-23
saying no they're rocking with you
cabbie uh both of you guys are walking
away with a hoodie
uh we got chi guy9 saying yes
yes sir actually and then we got
maxiecrymore69
saying yes uh with the what the gift
what the deadpool gift
uh cabbie cabbie
let me break something down to you we
are riding with the yes here
we have a man named wardell
curry on the court like if wardell's
wardale curry's on the court and there's
anything pertaining to three-pointers
made and he's on the court i'm
rocking with it every time i'm rocking
with every time and in fact
steph made the three last week to make
us uh
win the three by two the second game so
i'm rocking with the warriors every
single time
and uh i can see my guy two-way wiggins
hey he's in the he's in the top 10
in the mvp part of my game i'll start
start boarding
oh yeah yeah the arsenal arsenal
all-star yeah you're right
but uh two-way wigs man i can see him
popping the three kev
i can see him popping the three in the
first uh listen
i i don't you know i look i'm gonna ride
with the family because that's what
that's what we are on group chat so
if you guys want to ride with us make
sure to check out br betting social for
the link
to the 3x2 on fanduels the only place in
america you can get
the three by two is on fanduel so salute
to our friends over there
um g money you mentioned mvp let's get
to some mvp conversation because
before the season luca doncic was the
pre
presumptive mvp favorite and then last
week it flipped
lebron james supplanted young luka
doncic as the mvp
favorite and then nikola jokic went out
and dropped 47 on the best team in the
nba
ending utah's 11 game wintry you know
what i'm gonna stop talking let's just
take a look back at joker at work
boy what a great result clarkson having
a terrific season his yoke it spins it
up and it may be
four to shoot another three by yoke in
the lane around the corner
put it up and in jokic wheels in
the left-hand lay-in is good coming in
and he scores so he has tied his career
high
with 47 points also has 11 rebounds five
assists
two steals yo joker's
a touch with the basketball as like
johan sebastian bach
on the piano i can't think of a serbian
composer so i just my default is bach
but either way
jokic is just nice with it so an
impressive performance
let's take a look at the current mvp
odds we'll see lebron james at the top
still with plus 350
but there's been some movement there's
nikola jokic at number two at plus 440
he went from
plus 650 last week jumped up to plus 440
on the back of that 47
point performance and beads right there
plus 550
he had back to back 30 and 10 games greg
who does the audience
love for nba mvp right now
cabbie i'm just blown away we got the
producer giving us your kids highlights
we got
you talking about him we got him second
in the mvp
i just gotta know audience everybody in
the comments let me know is it cap or no
cap that jokic will win the mvp this
season like is it a real shot is that
cap
or is that no cap like we need to know
drop it below
uh and also let us know who you think is
gonna win the mvp give us your take now
kelly
we were just talking about this last
week did you change your mind by any
chance
it's not that i changed my mind and i'm
with you guys i think the joker has a
real shot
but right now it's lebron versus
everyone okay
this dude is my age he doesn't take any
time off
i mean what happened to load management
come on lebron you're just supposed to
like
take a night off because your hammy's
sore or something
this dude is an absolute machine he
refuses to quit
you know why because he wants another
mvp knob that's why and he's probably
gonna get it
do i think there's a ton of value in
betting him here no gabby's gonna lose
all his money
when lebron james wins because he's got
too many dang tickets out
there and uh he's not going to break
even but that being said
it's hard to bet against the king right
now i do have five
futures on nba mvp and among them are
lebron james and nicola jokic
and mb nba writers they love a narrative
they love
first-time winners and they love
advanced metrics i'm not going to jump
in too much
uh salute to john hollinger who invented
the player efficiency rating
but when you go to basketball reference
which is basically the bible for
basketball
they have an mvp tracker and i quote
this tracker is built on the model using
previous voting results
and also these players are these are
players
that voters are likely to target so on
their mvp tracker they have a
probability
lebron james has a 6.2 percent
probability rate to win the nba mvp
nikola jokic 43 this guy
is producing at all nba levels
largely without an all nba teammate
like lebron has in anthony davis jamal
murray saves all that for the playoffs
so and this is a regular season award
so i'm leaning nicola jokic both for the
narrative
the dude's basically a walking triple
double and
the nba voters might reward him for
being a first-time
nba mvp candidate g-money is there
anybody seeing nicola yokic in the in
the comments
are they all riding with kelly and
lebron raymond james
cabbie i see a whole bunch of caps in
the comments
don't get just legit though if it was
cap or no cap that if joking was winning
no cap you guys want to know like how
out of the loop i am i thought cap was a
good thing
that's why i was making the cap
reference now i know but it worked it
still worked though
it was capped that is that jokic is uh
in the mix guide you money
jesus we gotta help you
here we go i'm in the comments call me
ricky says
cap i'm giving him a hoodie uh here we
go i
not luca doncha says cap i'm also
giving them a hoodie uh we got
slim reaper 22 says stop the cap cabbie
he says stop the cap
oh tanker uh tanker is going with uh
bradley beal bradley bill that's an
interesting one that's an
interesting one kelly you have mikey 824
rocking with you and lebron james
uh rainey raimi is saying cap cabbie all
right i'm
i'm done into the comment i'm done with
the oh actually hold on
raymie also commented kevin durant hold
on i got to show you guys
i got to show you guys this you see
kevin durant right there the real mvp
the real mvp got me guess what raymie
it never does you're right guess what
raymie guess what raymie
i am riding with you i am riding with
you i am riding with you
kevin durant cabbie that's who i'm
riding with i'm riding with kevin durant
the audience is all over the place i
just know one thing they do not think
jokic
is winning mvp that is one thing that
they do not wait g-money
are you kevin k.d are you only rocking
with katie just because somebody put
a meme in the in the chat or is there
some other reason oh
cabbie he's mr efficiency
that's that's just what he balls he's he
i mean come on cabbie do i got to go
over some of his numbers
he just scored he just put up 28 37 32
like come on any shooting like oh bobby
i'm with greg
i do think that all three of these guys
have a real shot i mean that's why
they're priced that way
look if the nets can get in first place
in the east and kind of hang tight
through the playoffs i know it's a
regular season nod
it's all going to be because of kevin
durant hey hey
and kevi and kelly you've been preaching
value to us this whole time kelly since
the beginning
true the beginning look at this value
right here kd sitting at plus 750
we know the nets are gonna be finishing
the top three top two
maybe in the east kd
i'm telling you guys okay so so speaking
of kd
it's officially come back season for
both kevin durant
and our dude greg ivory and greg's
achilles heel this season
has been successfully has been trying to
successfully
pick a five leg single game parlay
it is it's caused much consternation for
our babyface assassin
and on top of that there's a 500 bet
between kelly
and greg that he will not hit a five leg
single game parlay
so far this season g-money is
has no money he is over six let's
actually take a look at last week's
ticket
uh from the golden state game wow that's
a lot of x's
one for five on the five leg single game
parlay
g money we gotta do better than baton
200 tabby yep
i mean you're absolutely right we're
gonna wear it we are gonna wear it but i
do want to say i do want to say
at least three of those x's that you
just saw was
one point away from being the check mark
the bookmakers of fanduel are just so
good aren't they greg isn't that weird
yeah you don't listen to me ever when i
tell you about betting all these overs
you're paying a premium for our dude's
step
every single time it's just so weird it
was just one point away
yeah we were just one point away but
that is okay
kelly that is that is okay that's that's
absolutely fine
all right so tonight denver nuggets
los angeles lakers talk to us homie what
are you putting together tonight
all right here we go here we go let's
start it off with your guy cabbie this
is your boy i paid i paid tribute
i'm this five team parlay is a tribute
to you two and your mvp uh
candidates okay okay i'll just throw
that out there here we go starting off
with your guy cabbie yo
nicola yokitch we're gonna go over 23
and a half points tonight
he's gonna go over 23.5 points tonight
you say that's money okay we got cabbie
approvals so let's move on
let's move on so we're gonna stick with
your guy cabbie
the joker we're gonna go over 10 and a
half
rebounds we're gonna go over ten and a
half rebounds i see him grabbing boards
i mean
cabbie you just said he knew i know i
know
he can do both though i feel like it's
got to be one or the other
with this but he just called him an mvp
candidate
he's true okay listen p candidates this
get it done no this is true this is true
but like
jokic like there's tres harrell and then
there's anthony davis
also grabbing reba and lebron james also
grabbing rebounds tonight
against the denver nuggets you're
contradicting yourself
no i know i know listen if they get the
win if denver gets the win
or at least they cover the plus five i
mean better to get the win then yeah
like jokic is the mvp but for that
that particular profit the the over on
the rebounds
that one concerns me a little bit but
sorry let's keep going because there we
go
here we go let's let's keep on moving
all right let's keep it moving
uh i got same i'm staying with your guy
cabbie the joker we're gonna go over
one and a half threes he's gonna stretch
it out tonight he's gonna stretch it out
tonight
he's gonna hit that point total he's
gonna hit that rebound and he's gonna
hit two are you expecting a like
kelly to play any defense
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i said are you expecting
lakers not to play any defense
no uh i think they're gonna it looks
like gary's might be really good
you're gonna play defense uh it's gonna
be a good game
uh moving on here we go to your person
kelly to your uh
mvp candidate lebron james we're gonna
this is for you kelly actually this is
for you we're gonna rock with the
under here the under two and a half
three points made uh we're rocking with
the under we're gonna ride that pretty
hard
i do not see lebron having an offensive
game today against his nuggets defense
greg i don't know man i do not see him
having a game today
and then you finally taken under and i
don't even like it oh
okay sorry go ahead and then and then
we're gonna round it off with lebron
james
over eight and a half assists
over eight and a half assists lbj
we know he's the king of assists i i
don't hate that one
i just think it's probably it's probably
going to land on eight and then we're
gonna have to hear about how it was so
close
because you paid a premium to bet lebron
james to kiss
excuse me assist king over and he ain't
gonna have that many
yeah jim money if if braun decides to be
like the alpha dog tonight
then he's gonna like he might be
lighting it up on you with
points scored and not being a
distributor like he normally is
and whenever braun plays in a game
against someone who's you know
who's also an mvp candidate he wants to
assert himself so
i'm i'm concerned with the assist too
bro i i don't know
but what's what's the what's the value
on this long shot actually let's take a
look let's pull up the ticket let's pull
up the ticket they said i'm off the
henny in the comments i ain't off
i ain't off no hennessy right now i'm
just off of straight
starbucks and vibes but let's go y'all
see the ticket right there y'all see it
once 250 dollars pretty nice
fifty dollars go turn it into a quick
ban ski
quick you feel me quick band uh
yeah and we go rock we rocking with that
tonight and let's get it done
well well good luck sir if that uh again
if that 500 comes
or if you if you hit this five leg
partly not only do you get a band
you get 500 from kelly kells who's
probably going to make more than that
this weekend the super bowl
anyway listen uh thank you very much for
tapping into the group chat
presented by fanduel remember three
things that you learned here today
we are riding with steph curry to
outscore luka doncic in their matchup
tonight
don't be afraid to sprinkle a couple of
unders when building a single
game parlay and tap in with g-money greg
ivory on vr betting's instagram
live tonight for a fun time and break
good vibes only alongside kelly stewart
and greg ivory we are my name is kathy
richards and we are leaving the group
chat peace
[Music]
[Music]
you